hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's Help Wanted we've got just one
two three four five more challenges to
go we're not over yet we've got the dark
rooms which shouldn't be too bad to be
perfectly honest so if these go smooth
I'm open that I won't be too stressed
about this
I just don't know all the timings gonna
be in the darkness but I'm gonna try it
real do it in two wait wait wait a
minute wait a minute
why am i tiny why am i teensy tiny oh
okay alright okay
I'm tiny that's alright because I may be
accurate to my own height right now but
you not gonna be me uh-huh now with your
no with your big old teeth and your
tangley dick yeah not this time I may be
small but I'm mighty I got big old fists
yeah you want one none at this would you
witch oh yeah okay alright so I think
it's the same type of game except for
some reason I'm tiny I gotta wait a long
longer because the otherwise I'm gonna
die okay
damnit oh I'm gonna die [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
hey yeah don't actually eat nothing of
me eat absolutely little of me okay
alright okay what the hell are you what
are you I'm here with Dave there okay
all right
that is just probably not true what are
you talking about I'm going to eat your
soul right now it's your ass
did you just threaten me my ass no
that's all what everything um listen I I
don't consent to any of that so I'm just
gonna
I would actually leave you there because
you are creepy as hell and I'm not even
gonna bother with you
nightmare BB why does nightmare be me oh
those are balloons oh boy Oh nightmare
baby's gonna be a big boy oh we're gonna
have a big balloon boy aren't we
balloon boy whole ship
oh I'm not tiny though that's good how
am i how am I supposed to deal with this
hey you still there you're still even on
that go away okay yeah he's on the
ground over there I think
all right this is fine did he move he's
real close right there that's okay okay
whoa no way I don't know where he went
but he's there all right that actually
got me that got me real good yeah I got
me real good okay but not gonna i I
think I punched my knuckle cuz my
knuckle hurts oh really oh okay I guess
I'm going back in now all right are you
son of a [ __ ]
there you are okay cool good you throw
your balloon party your stupid big
bubbly balloon party you do whatever you
want because I don't care you're gonna
be a face-full this next time you come
at me huh you come at me unprepared you
get unn
your ass is gonna be unprepared for this
fist damn it I gotta stop threatening
people with a good time
oh great great great oh I gotta lose
guys I gotta lose oh I can't eat the
Loon Oh
my lung oh [ __ ] Oh tits do you know
about this you know about this one hey
touch you oh you're just outside the
zone okay all right you'll be okay
you'll be no touch but don't get you
anyway do you know about this how big
this is do you know do you know how big
they are there's gonna suck I have no
idea how they're gonna change it but it
was bad before it was like impossible
before how am I gonna be able to do it
now alright whatever okay all right I
remember how to do it with the
flashlight stupid oh they're all oh hi
oh they're all if they're all like that
then how no I didn't forget my I know
come on
oh well I'm doomed there's got to be
what like one spazzing out somewhere I'm
just shaking up a new yeah yeah I don't
like it when you stare at me kind of
give us a dead giveaway giveaway wait
what hello who saw that I saw one up
there I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
no I don't know thank you okay I'm doing
okay I see you here your call I hear
your call come on give me give me give
me give me just little flashes little
little flushes that's all I need Oh
little flickers it's gonna be real hard
on everybody's eyes please what you
smooth all right okay back in easy-peasy
easy-peasy me easy my pieces I think
little flickers is exactly what we need
to beat this they definitely are
distinct
no no you didn't hear any call oh I
didn't call I didn't call I did not call
I intentionally didn't call I would
never call I'm not that type of person
wait I saw be another one around here
somewhere
I will not die thank you for the
reassurance okay
so there's only so many places that they
can be as long as I keep checking
everywhere
whoa I see you up there you were hard to
spot admittedly yeah I well I mean I
know a lot of things but number one of
them is that I'm going to live very hind
the brain thing going on in my head
where were you where were you freaking
get you every time
okay all right so that's how it's gonna
be huh
[Music]
boom wait this is the whole disappearing
act thing you can't just pop away once I
find you I feel like there's more I
think there's a problem
it's just flickering because it can make
a move good so far oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] but
they do the finger fight if I see them
but I flick her away Frick okay they're
only need so many zones they're only in
so many zones so long as I find the
zones that they are in then I check the
zones it's top center and up is that one
over there right yeah too much power I
can check these zones quicker where are
you how how oh I see you okay I'm
looking for the eyes it's real tricky
but I don't think it's that bad
okay I've missed one I know I have I my
hind brain is telling me that something
is oh yeah right there got you both of
you Oh ooh that's another one that's
another hiding place that I've missed
back there that was real hard to see
cool good good good
good so far so good okay what the hell
oh [ __ ] okay that's okay oh my god oh
damn it okay I was very close to the end
but I had lost track of one I could feel
it in my head it's weird that I can like
feel it like I know I've seen something
and it's not there like something is out
of place it's it's a big Where's Waldo
says where's one goal one boob [ __ ] are
you up there
no one was hurt you're there easy easy
easy easy I got him I got you guys you
can't hide from me doing so good doing
so good so good so far supers ok they're
scooping up they're speeding their
scoopers [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Harrier if I don't find one every few
seconds towards the end here no I don't
that's right
ok up close very close there you know
you're there no no no wait is that trick
you sicken me
you forgive me RJ oh I think you were
treating me
exotic beverage ooh is that like exotic
butters 300%
garbs oh that doesn't seem about right
but okay
I'll take it yeah logical I like logic
logic is good
oh you're gone okay all right okay oh no
this one was impossible as it was enough
oh [ __ ]
this one was impossible how in the hell
how what what the who [ __ ] what what
okay
I'm sorry oh [ __ ] me oh my oh they all
move oh my god oh my god oh this is oh
this is awful I'm gonna just stand here
and look at this and die but holy [ __ ]
oh god I can't I can't just kill me oh
there's multiple of you okay but you
don't seem to be moving that much okay
ordinarily I'd be dead by now if it was
the other huh huh huh what happens I go
here what was that oh [ __ ] oh you
weren't even in play it oh wait oh
you're you're lol oh okay yeah I'm dumb
dead
just kill me just kill me kill me kill
me just kill me I hate this I hate this
I hate this I hate this I hate that I
hate
oh hi I hate oh god I don't know where
you went oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] that in every
way
okay then I'm too close to you Oh too
close still okay not getting any farther
I didn't see eyes
okay there's eyes okay too close to that
oh boy okay I come in
oh boy okay come with me this way this
way this way
Oh keep coming with me
[Music]
that's dangerous that's real dangerous
okay we're real close Oh hmm too close
too close too close okay that's a plus
that's way it was way too close way to
us great applause come on this way this
way this way this way
[Music]
okay oh wait what oh don't don't
jump-scare me I I don't like this I
can't grab it what why can't I grab
don't you want to be eaten by me huh you
wanna be eaten you come on I know you do
come on where are you give me just give
me a tantalizing taste to you come on oh
I just want a sweet treat that can't be
beat oh come on please
please with your buck teeth and your
over saturated fats mmm yum yum yum I
want the sugar get in me come on give me
some sugar
please please please oh all right well
that's uh it's apparently a ghost
cupcake it don't exist in this point a
reality booth okay fine then goodbye ooh
I guess you won't be eating today stupid
okay so that is oh [ __ ] pizza party wait
why does that look like that
wait a minute what does that look like
that that's that's clearly the curtain
there wait that one doesn't have that
one wait wait that's that one that one
has stars on it that one doesn't have
stars on and remember one time like in
the first episode I did to this when
that curtain came up what was that all
about why did I see them then there's a
lot of questions that I don't have
answers to but for now we're gonna get
out of nightmare world and we are going
to continue that in the next one so
we've only got one thing left and it's
probably going to be the ultimate
challenge in this game but I've been
pretty good at all of these challenges
thus far so thank you everybody so much
for watching there's probably only going
to be one more episode of this game but
might I say this has been a really cool
experience it's been one of the best
five nights it's it's probably one of my
favorite five nights at Freddy's games
ever made just because it's so immersive
it's so terrifying it really brings the
the fear to life it's just awesome I
love this a lot so thank you everybody
so much for watching check out the other
five nights at Freddy's stuff I've done
in the description below or in the
recommended videos subscribe for more
cool stuff ring that Bell
hit that like thanks guys so much for
being there and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
[Music]